well there's a what a performance here
in the thai bricks you've won it all in
st louis
anything you want to say to your fans
yeah it feels great um i didn't expect
to be in the toy breaks because jan was
completely winning today against hans so
um it's a miraculous thing that in
canada in the toy breaks so i'm really
happy
that i i was already happy that i had
the chance to play against him and
and
he's obviously a very strong player so
it's not easy to beat him but
i think i played very well in the toy
breaks tell us a little bit about those
tie breaks we'll just go through a
couple of the moments won't take that
long but here after the move d5 you
spent half the time allotted to you
what were you thinking yeah it's i
completely missed the move after c5 um i
missed d5 so
and it's a very important position
because white is getting e4 and i have
to be very concrete otherwise i get very
passive so
i think i i don't know if i found the
correct
way but i think it's it's okay and i
couldn't see how it wants to break
so i was happy with my decision after
all so what were you sure that you had
this draw in the bag
uh no it was very tricky because my
knight is out of the game and yeah
but yeah but i couldn't i never saw an
advantage for him but so it's not easy
of course of course in the second game
you play an idea that you wanted to show
in the classical against shaq you came
in you said that you had actually
missed on the move order it didn't seem
like he was prepared yeah he completely
forgot the idea i think
the line is not knight a6 so
um but i don't know if i punished it
well but i think it was interesting i
couldn't find a better way so
yeah in general the itrimo is a good
idea i think and it's the business
problem
all right and finally
in this position
yeah
your feelings
when he goes queen e7 yeah
it was shocking yeah because
you you have to think about e5 but okay
he's very tired and he was completely
winning today so he's a bit frustrated
so
uh it's kind of understandable but yeah
you have to normally see e5 but i think
i have a very promising position
instead of queen e7 but yeah it's a
it's a good gift
um yeah it's it was a very good feeling
here you didn't hesitate you kept your
tactical awareness all throughout
extremely sharp how do you do it how
does everybody get tired but not you uh
yes today i was lucky i made a quick
draw and he was playing for five hours i
am sure if he had a quick game also he
would have been more sharp and he would
have been sharper and
better simply but
i was lucky that he played a very long
game
so
but in general i think everybody played
a decent tournament here okay some
player of course they didn't but
in general everybody was in a great
shape i think and we saw a very high
quality tournament
so
yeah i'm happy with the my play at least
and
we'll see what happens in 1960
960 is certainly a different beast you
ready for it yeah it's my first time
playing over the world 960 so
um it's a it's a very interesting event
of course i'm looking forward to play
gary
and
i have to take revenge because last year
i lost in online
against him so
we will see what happens hey guys join
us here with the winner of well
everything here in st louis
yeah congratulations very well really
really congratulations uh uh we'll look
forward to the fisher 960 as well uh ali
raisin
as we
get ready to say our goodbyes for